right foot left foot slide that foot
right foot side here's something you
didn't expect to see Anthony Hopkins
dancing to Drake on tick-tock yeah I'm
serious right foot left foot right foot
side
the 82 year old a list actor jumped in
on the rapper's Tootsie slide challenge
and I'm not gonna lie he's pretty
freaking good guys he's good right foot
right foot side then the two Pope star
extended the challenge to Sylvester
Stallone and Arnold Schwarzenegger he
even called them out at the end of the
video with personalized messages quoting
their movies like rocky and the
Terminator Anthony posted the tik-tok to
Twitter writing Drake I'm late to the
party but better late than never
of course Anthony isn't the only celeb
to dive into tik-tok land during
quarantine Dame Judi Dench also got in
on the craze joining her 22 year old
grandson virtually last month
[Music]
then there's Jane Fonda my name is James
yeah she brought back her signature
workout method to help fight the climate
crisis during this whole sequestration
also getting in on some tic toc choreo
Justin and hailey Bieber and Courtney
Cox and in April Nicole Polizzi aka
Snooki told ET how her five-year-old
daughter Giovanna has been teaching her
how to use the social media platform you
guys have been passing the time and
Quarantine with some tick-tock action
and you've got a really beautiful
sidekick you're adorable Giovanna
here's teaching whom how to tick tock
and how did that all kick off for y'all
well she's got me teaching me because I
just feel like I'm too old for this yeah
I feel like it's like a teenage thing
and I'm 32 and I feel like I'm 60 so
she's been doing chick talk to their
cousins and I'm like what the hell is
six off so I ended up going on and she's
been teaching me all the moves and
everything so I love the fact that my
tick-tock is all about my kids like
that's what I want it to be I don't need
to try and be sexy dancing doing these
moves like I own time for that